how's the gum resumes beautiful welcome
back to evil within hospice yes well
smart Feeney fruited here years ago he'd
come here thinking it was familiar than
safe you know where we are just ahead is
the hospice my brother runs he'll take
us in that didn't answer my question I
honestly don't know for all I know I'm
losing my mind and you're just a
delusion but I'd like to think I still
have a shred of dignity in you're a yes
I hope his brother's not a jerk to
everyone is a jerk in his game he's
right he just goes tackle everything
this head-on alright so we play this
part before maybe you've seen it maybe
you don't so there's this one part in
there I think where his brother is
um I'm not gonna go there because yeah
because I've already explored it so I'll
just go straight to the point in this
chapter kind of I know yeah it's kind of
cool that you can choose what you want
to go in this game if you want to
explore more you can do it don't go so
fast shut up I'm Sanok you know one
tells me not to wait what so I'm just
gonna go straight to Leslie I know she's
in the basement I wonder it I think it
will be a little different down there
Leslie Oh Leslie so yeah if you want to
look at a more extra in gameplay or
whatever just look up those videos this
filled with blood I feel like it's gonna
do it again do it again oh my god we'll
have it done do it again all I want to
know is a little fun Leslie let's make
up oh [ __ ] he come from
Oh doc I think something's coming
ah come I do I even have anything
alright that's a bottle
alright let's hide hi Brenda so what's
coming exactly something scary
well Jay says oh my god where did it
come from
I swear to God and see oh it's
impossible there's nothing to be afraid
of you [ __ ] impossible bounce aah
oh god no I punched him is he supposed
to be impossible how the [ __ ] do you get
impossible Jeff large victims Butler
cocaine Ravana sir tell me yeah yes I
think he died no burn Oh [ __ ] that
was all of them rise place is a
deathtrap is the [ __ ] irresistible
monsters do I look like I can deal with
us
what kind of difficulty am i playing on
like get out I need to upgrade my [ __ ] I
need it going this way I need a mirror
station Leslie you sound like a [ __ ] so
like please don't I'm not not a brain
goo look how much brain go I have look
how much stupid oh he dropped a lot yeah
give me aa nerd gimme a dead brain do ya
well that's cool that it is a little
different at least but Jesus what's got
oh yeah now I mean nothing's gonna
happen I'm not spoiling anything
you kind of look like that actor from
henan ball collectively losing our minds
losing our minds collectively losing our
mind
Oh God
okay so that guy is an [ __ ] we know
that ruzek
it is you who the hell are you no all
right where he said don't father so I
guess I better not dick JK hey goddamnit
what happened doctor wisely come on
everybody
I remember that all right we'll think
I'm supposed to find a door or something
let's see a No okay let's go backwards
sin well [ __ ] you too then how nice
very the shining I like it very [ __ ] very
cool I like it
oh yeah now we're down here this piece
ish oh it's so disgusting this game
really is something else you gotta give
them props for coming up with this [ __ ]
so disgusting oh we got something there
I need that definitely me do that I'm so
low on ammo and they literally take like
three shots in the head while they're
like I yeah I need you to I need you in
my laughs me to stay let's try and use
these traps for our game I'm not gonna
disarm them oh yeah this part yeah it's
gonna be fun
hi Rubik you piece of [ __ ] I hate him
look how many oh god alright um yeah we
don't even know what okay let's just try
and get as many headshots our god is too
fatty and yeah I'm not good with
headshots under pressure under pressure
dundun this is [ __ ] ridiculous and
there's no donkeys involved no donkeys
oh god don't hug me I'm Swedish we
didn't we're allergic to hugs go gotta
get that boom boom boom go go go go
embryo I wish that I was like 40 paja
like 40 pi
fam had a lamb are you [ __ ] kidding
me this isn't some kind of sick joke
go
go go go go go go
reload I have one [ __ ] bullet left we
have to make something okay this is all
good all good in the hood how do they
make it past No
are you [ __ ] kidding me that doesn't
kill him it's in some kind of sick
[ __ ] joke what where did he come from
stop don't you know who I am okay now I
have the perfect strategy don't even
worry about it for us alright guys I
have a little gift
it's called a grenade up your [ __ ]
ass I think you ought [ __ ] oh you
[ __ ] he doesn't die
what is he made of this is some kind of
sick [ __ ] joke
okay that takes care of a couple of them
yes yes oh god what do you want
huh nope nope [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] get off me car
where do they all come from Santa Santa
where do the evil alien see I don't even
have near enough to kill all of them I
can kill them with this are they is it
like more coming or some [ __ ] I don't if
this is the joke I am NOT into it
alright what does this do
yeah that helps
no [ __ ] way this is normal difficulty
alright guys if you can just be like
nice and come up here that'd be great
Thank You ppreciate eh oh well I did the
trick didn't it okay now you're on the
wrong side ah what are you doing hey
Bryce I'm so sad oh no oh my god I
almost died
this is redonkulous this is one little
[ __ ] I can't ah no no he's coming I
gotta get there boom boom boom boom um
why does this door have to keep closing
all right here we go there we go alright
come here BAE BAE
why don't you come there we go waiting
patiently for BAE hey BAE
don't run walk yeah that's right no dude
I said Rock now [ __ ] justify survive
summon a booty bro oh oh oh what the
[ __ ] is what shut our PlayStation when
BAE comes over for Christmas you only
get one shot this is not the chance to
blow this opportunity
wait why you're not dead you're not
you're supposed you're supposed to
you're supposed to die
what is the point of living if they
don't die that was deep
the timing on this [ __ ] thing is just
what are you doing you want to take a
[ __ ] bath and go go to bath it's
great there no for the love of Jess for
the love of penis it is it dead is it
dead hallelujah it is dead that is
[ __ ] hard so [ __ ] hard
that was [ __ ] impossible maybe if I
throw that grenade a little better that
might not be that hard but those fatties
um I should just what is the difficulty
I'm playing on this is some kind of
weird [ __ ] joke survival what does
that even mean
change standard difficulty will [ __ ] me
then
I wouldn't really call anything about
that standard I would [ __ ] call it
out standing that's what I would call it
jaysis well that door is locked isn't it
I remember this part bros close your
eyes is part of horrible this part is
the worst the worst part ABS that it's
like oh no a dead cow again oh nevermind
it's a dead demon baby that wants to do
we inside this everyone's well you are a
smart Spanish Spaniard um isn't this
door supposed to open there we go thank
you
alright good thing I remember that dent
and edit and and edit and and edited and
did it end end end end end end end end
edited in Denton Denton I don't trust
you
I will let you want ad or they tempt you
they [ __ ] tempt you oh god oh god
what is happening I don't want to know
I'm just gonna go oh god she respawns he
knows [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
well I became hot the [ __ ] trap this
game is just a giant [ __ ] troll just
wanting to suck your ass I've played it
before and I suck so much ass like I
don't even like to suck ass
i'ma let you one time I want the go
gave me the go so much good goo goodies
drop listen your ass is about to be
missing up don't think I didn't see you
there
time to run ten I wish you could rush
with you I'll what what's with his
[ __ ] attitude what's up with you I
would be like supervise you - its
therapy
oh thanks elevator I'm glad I can almost
trust you and this piece of [ __ ] I'll
trust you though that was fun let's
never ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever do that again thank
you twice is twice too many huh this
game in this game n no game man no no no
I don't wanna make it with you why
ah so funny hey there
I
oh I didn't remember it like this what's
going on
ah
praise the Lord of Jesus condoms that
was close
that's not that's not what you say you
don't just oh damn I guess I was pretty
close almost got eaten by the worst
demon I [ __ ] ever seen well I guess I
was pretty close and now this [ __ ] is
gonna come great oh [ __ ]
he almost got me he's like ah almost had
him that time hey too bad I can run he's
such a doofus nicer duper's duel
Schnabel yeah
can't go anywhere in this game this game
hates you this game makes fun of you I'm
like shocked and now I'm jumping if I
don't die now I'm just gonna go to space
and yeah anyone can survive that this is
where the chapter ends for me because
I'm a DuPage NASA double Snapple crazies
please please slow prowess um I don't
know if it comes across with a little
editing magic but I struggle a spark on
this one okay I'm not gonna lie it was
hard but I liked it
anyway hope you guys enjoyed this
episode I had fun I like challenging
game don't get me wrong it's fun please
go ahead and hit like if you enjoy
watching this episode and you want to
support this series if you want more the
best way that the wind is do that so
thank you for doing that um I am gonna
be in Italy so it might take me two
extra days to get chapter 5 out should
be up on Saturday or Sunday so sorry
about that but anyway I'll see you there
as always stay awesome bros